bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors depuis quelques
années déjà la situation politique est
plutôt bancale haïti aujourd'hui on
assiste donc à cette querelle de
gouvernance
vous craignez que le pays ne sombre
davantage dans le chaos
c'est une nouvelle épreuve suite à
l'assassinât de jouvenel moïse mais il
faut faire confiance sans doute aux
acteurs locaux qui cherchent une
solution mais comme l'a souligné tout à
l'heure madalim aucune solution
constitutionnelle est viable en dehors
d'un accord politique parce que toutes
les institutions sont affaiblies à sont
mis à genoux elles ont été
instrumentalisés par joël moïse la
police nationale la cour de cassation le
conseil électoral provisoire également
l'absence d'un parlement d'un simple
totalité c'est à dire qu'il ya absence
de la chambre des députés et le sénat
n'existe mais une partie alors on
assiste donc à la population de 2 du
corps politique de josé luis c'est à
dire le camp physique disparaît le corps
politique est l'objet d'une
appropriation d'une part par le premier
ministre démissionnaire qui
reconnaissant le n'a aucune légitimité
de prétendre à exercer la fonction
puisque l époque il est porte
démissionnaire il ya un autre premier
ministre qui a été nommée la nomination
a été publié au journal officiel de la
république mais il n'est pas arrivé si
dans sa fonction
alors ça mène troisième acteur c'est le
président du sénat qui a reçu le vote de
ses pairs le 9 juillet mais il est
souple et non seulement par ses pairs
mais également par l'ensemble des
composantes de la société politique
c'est à dire les principales forces
partisanes
il y à un accord qui ait obtenu entre
cette masse y parle fox partisane et le
scénar me devais est prêté serment dans
les prochaines heures mais qui semble y
a encore quelques blocages et mais les
discussions se poursuivent
on a les pressions qu'il y a de la part
des acteurs locaux en haïti une
tentative d' exclure toute solution
externe parce qu'on voit bien claude
joseph s'appuie sur la sape huissier le
soutien international
c'est à dire sur l'appui de madame
lalime il faut le rappeler
l'onu ne s'est pas encore exprimé comme
institution il ya une position
personnelle individuelle de la part de
madame la lime madame lalime qui fait
l'objet des truzion d'interventionnisme
de la politique et était en haïti et qui
a toujours soutenu journal moïse donc on
attaque on est donc dans la continuité
de la politique onusienne à travers
madame lalime a à a
claude joseph mais la position de madame
la ligne l on est d accepter par
l'ensemble des membres de la communauté
internationale et en haïti a une
composante qui exercent une autorité
impérative sur la politique haïtienne
s'est uni c'est une structure qui
s'appelle le code groupe qui réunit non
seulement l'organisation des
nations-unies mais les états unis
d'amérique
l'union européenne alors dans ce
contexte international air a appelé au
maintien des élections qui sont prévues
en septembre prochain pour sortir de la
crise il faut passer par là est ce que
vous pensez qu'une entente serait
possible d'ailleurs entre les deux
hommes entre claude joseph et ariel
envie oui on pense ya possibilité qu'il
y à un accord une tente entre claude
joseph et paris orly mais il faut le
rappeler également la position de la
communauté internationale et les
complètement cette pouliche elle est
complètement inadapté parce que dans les
conditions actuelles il est pas possible
d'organiser des élections en haïti dans
les prochains mois il faudrait pas s'y
fier la société haïtienne se dit
désormais les gangs les gangs qui
représente une menace permanente sur la
vie quotidienne des haïtiens où nous
parlons les les quatre départements du
pays de son pack ses cibles et cela
depuis quatre mois et le gouvernement
haïtien et
et notamment jouzel moïse était en
connivence avec ses dindes pas soit ils
utilisaient ces dom comme étant une
ressource de sa survie politique
alors aucune élection n'est possible
aujourd'hui sans passif hissant à un
travail de pacification de la société
haïtienne qui viserait donc le
désarmement de ses goûts la création
d'un nouveau conseil électoral
provisoire
et puis la réconciliation entre les
haïtiens parce que pour le moment c'est
une société haïtienne très morcelé de
côté il ya les élites économie est
prédatrice qui maintiennent l'essentiel
des richesses du pays à la grande masse
qu'on peut appeler la communauté des
souffrances qui sont abandonnés à
eux-mêmes donc il faudrait donc cette
réconciliation et puis de l'autre il
faut créer un environnement propice à
l'investissement permettant permettant
de répondre aux défis aujourd'hui celui
de vaincre la misère la malnutrition et
la faim merci beaucoup en tout cas
jacques lizé d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
politologue et membre du laboratoire
caribéen de sciences sociales